now it's all about real fast food real
fast food should always grab your
attention with big gutsy flavors
fantastic aromas and be immediately
satisfying it should also be easy to
make and quick to cook and real fast
food
doesn't get much faster than my first
dish chicken stir-fry
with rice noodles some of the best
street food I've ever eaten was in Asia
every one of those little markets was
filled with smells of delicious food
that all centered around an Asian staple
noodles learn to cook those properly and
you'll be surprised how quick and easy
it is to knock off a delicious dinner
first off you're gonna soak our noodles
now these are rice noodles into a bowl
and just pour hot water over the rice
noodles soak and rehydrate 12 to 15
minutes to soften up if you've got to
walk perfect if not just a normal sized
frying pan with big sloping sides pan on
get it really nice and hot chicken
breast very lean hardly any fat on there
you've got this little Phyllis just
slice that off now the secret to getting
it really nice and thin and to cut it
into strips take your knife keep it nice
and flat on the board and sort of slice
it in half like a sort of scholar
like that we call this butterfly in the
chicken take a rolling pin and place
them gently roll over the chicken what
it does it sort of flattens it allows
you to slice it even thinner and the
thinner a slice of the chicken sort of
crisper it gets the quicker it cooks
slice it in half to start slicing these
nice thin slices and the good news is
one chicken breast can serve two or
three easily next wash your knife and
finally slice garlic
the thinner the garlic the crispier this
is a young tender broccoli just slice
them down what a bites to the broccoli
and normally you sort of paste the dish
with 1/3 noodles one-third vegetables on
one third of your protein chicken with a
dish that takes literally minutes to put
together it's really important to get
everything organized everything needs to
beat your fingertips touch of olive oil
pan really nice and ready just starting
to smoke drop the chicken in first just
salt pepper
open up those little strands of chicken
nice
[Music]
once we started to sear off the chicken
get the garlic in now let that get
really nice and crispy and the way to do
it is we're sort of spread all with
chicken the garlic of the side of the
pan you see why it's so important to cut
the chicken thin strips because the
colors and cooked at the same time is
not really really crucial
now that garlic get really nice and
crispy rocky in steel strings putting
raw broccoli in like that normally the
glancing volume water dry out but not
that crunch
now soy sauce that helps to season it
but also stains beautifully soy sauce in
lovely
exactly what I want now pick it out
to be a pan and little wipeout little
teaspoon of olive oil
get out what really nice the oiled again
drain your noodles
a beautiful this is a really exciting
way of finishing this quick stir-fry
very classic two eggs in whisk up the
eggs and give that a really good whisk
[Music]
sort of almost spread it but the side of
the pan lightly seasoned the eggs
noodles in chicken and broccoli in
[Music]
and give that a really nice mix and what
the actor sort of almost bring the dish
together
that eggs cooked
I'll show y'all that nice the even
distribution of chicken broccoli garlic
lovely they just finished that that
fresh line and they have a very simple
delicious stir-fry with rice noodles
[Music]
noodles are a fast-food staple and they
come in all shapes and sizes they're so
easy to cook healthy but really
delicious
here are three effortless recipes that
are ready literally in minutes
first up blue suit with poached egg and
spring onions
[Music]
and me so paste the boiling water
japanese miso has a wonderful deep
savory richness and is brilliant in
suits
grating fresh ginger
add dried shiitake mushrooms that have
been soaked in water
season with soy sauce crack an egg added
to the broth and poached for two to
three minutes
and thinly sliced portobello mushrooms
to a serving bowl put in fresh medium
egg noodles which will heat through in
the hot miso broth add spinach
[Music]
then simply spoon the broth into your
bowl
top with the egg and fresh chopped
spring onions
so simple so good and so delicious ready
in ten minutes
super fast noodle soup with poached egg
and spring onions my next easy dish
using the versatile noodle is stir-fried
pork noodles
first marinade pork mince and shall sing
rice wine a fortified Chinese wine soy
sauce and sesame oil
next my chopped ginger in hot olive oil
and garlic
[Music]
next add Szechuan peppercorns which have
a wonderful lemony flavor and gives a
pleasant tingling sensation
now add your marinated pork mince and
Brown if you want more seasoning and
extra soy sauce then add fiery chili
bean paste and rice wine vinegar
adding cooked egg noodles
mixed together
finally top with chopped spring onion
and toasted sesame seeds
[Music]
packed with flavor and on the table in
15 minutes delicious stir-fried pork
noodles
my next noodle dish you can knock up in
no time
is noodles with chili ginger and
lemongrass
[Music]
add chopped onions to hot olive oil
garlic chilli and fry
grating ginger next lemongrass first
batter with a knife doing this will help
release is wonderful lemony flavor and
scent now aromatic kaffir lime leaves
then ground cumin coriander and turmeric
next at cream coconut chicken stock fish
sauce and simmer
so rice vermicelli noodles in hot water
[Applause]
[Music]
drain and after your serving bowl pour
over the aromatic soup broth finish with
coriander and chopped chili
on the table in around 20 minutes
noodles with chili ginger and lemongrass
real fast food fast healthy delicious
free mouth-watering recipes guaranteed
to help you master the art of incredible
tasting noodles next five more my 100
top tips to make your home cooking
easier
rest up how to join the chicken for your
favorite real fast food dishes open up
the legs and just pierce the skin there
careful not to cut into the breast and
hand on top of the breast and pull the
drum back pop out and then slice the
knife straight across
there's the thigh there's the drum get
your thumb and feel to join and with the
weight of the knife just slice ease
through now two beautiful thighs now a
bit of a chef's tip halfway down the
drum just slice through onto the bone
and then from there scrape up the
tendons and then hand down nice and foul
on top now it's beautiful bone
presentation as it cooks it cooks evenly
now pull out the wing feel where the end
of the joint is and just slice in there
through
a beautiful big hole delicious wink
now this is the rolls-royce part two
breasts that's the breast bone there
place the chicken on the board and then
just slice down on the back of the crown
everyone always cuts around just tilt it
upwards straight through that way we get
straight to the center of the carcass
and therefore is no waste and look we
end up taking off his bump chicken
breasts nice - drums - sighs - wings -
breasts of chicken and one amazing
carcass for stock or not an ounce of
waste a great tip to stop your skewers
burning when you're making kebabs is to
serve them in water first or for skewers
with added flavor strip your rosemary
branches of their leaves and use instead
[Music]
for no fuss marinating my tip is to
place fish or meat in a plastic storage
bag while they marinate it's easy to
store and is less cleanup lime juice or
lemon juice make great marinades my tip
for getting maximum amount of juice from
a lemon or lime is to roll it hard under
your palm for a minute before juicing
lemons are also useful for rice add a
couple of drops of juice while you cook
it
keep your grains looking nice white and
bright
whether I'm knocking out fast food or
planning a feast
I want my dishes to be the tastiest they
can be and to do that I always start
with the best ingredients I can get my
shopping mantra is very simple knowledge
is crucial the more you know personally
about where you ingredients are from and
how they produce the better so asked
lots of questions and learn here's a
quick rundown of the six most useful
vinegars and what you can do with them
all make great fast and easy dressings
with the exception of malt vinegar use
this for pickling or splashing on your
fish and chips tangy red wine vinegar is
great for marinades red meats and calves
liver white wine vinegar is good for
sweet sour recipes as well as butter
sauces sherry vinegar nutty and virgin
on the sweet side this perfect splash
into gazpacho or ting with sweet season
veg like asparagus or artichokes
while cider vinegar tart and fruity is
ideal for pickling fruit and for
vegetable chutneys rice vinegar is an
essential for Chinese and Japanese
dishes and is lovely and mild in flavor
balsamic vinegar widely considers as a
king of vinegars is the one I use time
and time again dark and syrupy it's
sweet and sharp taste is a great
addition if you frying juicy steaks or
chops in marinades
or on fresh sweet strawberries like fine
wine the price reflects the time has
been matured anywhere between three and
twenty five years look out for the stem
to make sure you're getting the genuine
article from Italy's modern the
reasoning you can pay up to two hundred
quid for just a hundred mils of
top-quality bass summer vinegar like
this one
and if you do splash out on one of the
fine types you'll have to taste it to
believe it
[Music]
there's a wealth of classic fast food
dishes we know and love from hot dogs
and kebabs to tacos and burgers but the
great thing about making them at home is
you can throw away the rule book and get
creative
my next easy recipe is a miniature
version of an American favorite the
burger smoky pork sliders with barbecue
sauce
everyone loves a burger there are true
fast-food original and that's the
exciting thing about street food you can
take an old classic like that and
reinvent it into something really
exciting what do you think of a burger
what you need is a great source and I
like smoky barbecue ghost hand in glove
with a great burger start by finely
chopping one onion and three cloves of
garlic a small pan tablespoon of olive
oil onions and garlic into the pan a
nice seasoning salt and pepper now the
secret of a good barbecue sauce is that
really important camera zation to begin
with a nice tablespoon brown sugar it
darkens the onions but it really starts
to sort of give that nice syrupy body to
the sauce
I'll put a little bit of heat in there
now a nice teaspoon of smoked paprika
that's the important part of working
with spices look them out almost sort of
burn off that rawness especially with a
smoked paprika it's exactly where I
wanted to go onions and garlic
beautifully caramelized cider vinegar in
reduce that down now I've got a
fantastic smoky base to complete the
sauce I'm making my life really easy and
adding pre-made Worcester sauce and
tomato ketchup turn that out for two to
three minutes now depending on how thick
you like the barbecue sauce that term is
how long you cook it out for I don't
want it to be too runny but I don't want
to think either that's the consistency
you're looking for
we turn down the gas
and such a season now take that out is
the kind of source that I'd like to have
sort of bottled up in the fridge it's
great for sandwiches but guys Brittany
well with these sliders homemade smoky
barbecue sauce give a panel it white now
start the mix to the sliders to give my
mix a really interesting flavor and
texture I'm gonna be using unsmoked Bank
bacon I travel all over the world and I
spent a lot of time in the States
they know how to make a great slider Tex
like as beef sliders chicken sliders
there's almost like a way of having a
burger but on a much smaller miniature
level little TSP of olive oil on that
bacon to get really nice and crispy
bacon in this just gives the really nice
sort of chunky delicious makes on
texture and pork is perfect for slider
[Music]
and selfish long
slots are a lot sweeter than your normal
white onion five five five and in now
that baking is getting really nice and
crispy I want a bit of heat in there a
little two teaspoons a smoked paprika in
there when we see these sliders in the
states from one portion there's like
four or five of them little mini one
bite us incredible now take your pork
just open up give that a really nice
evening so important you can't season a
slider after you've cooked it's
impossible so seasoned it nicely baked
now that's nice and crispy just take
little touch kitchen wrong just drain
that off there nice pat that nice and
dry
I want all that nice sort of crisping us
in there beautiful mix all that in take
a nice ball and sort of roll it size of
a golf ball
get it nice and round first and then
three fingers just add that down don't
flap them too thin otherwise be able to
cook and they go sort of dry
because sliders are bite-sized burgers
designed to go in small buns you don't
want to make them too big good got a pan
nice and hot tablespoon of olive oil
when a slider is literally that affect
about an inch thick we going to take two
and a half to three minutes Sign In
tell them over lovely once you've turned
them tilt the pan and just spoon all
that juice back into them leave my mouth
watering up very easy to dry the pork
out so just feeling it now or you think
is nice and firm the little touch of
springiness in the center happy rhodes
add your cheese now still gets nicely
melted I'm using wedges or smoked
cheddar and it has that nice sort of
sorry smoky creaminess to the slider
finely shredded baby gem lettuce just
take those buns make sure they're sliced
nice and evenly take your lettuce quite
generous with my lettuce it's a nice
thin slice of tomato take your burgers
see that cheese
you feed melted the barbecue sauce place
the top on
and that is my version the slider that
is small dynamic but packed full of
flavor I'll take that over Hamburg any
day
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips and a hundred recipes to stake
your life on and you'll literally be
cooking yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the App Store for
details go on get cooking